.
BUT
VERIFYHE THO
JILL DOUGHERTY IS PROFESSOR Y CR
H
COVERINGTHANCE PBLY HA
SHIFTED MAYBE NOT.WHAT DO YOU TC
THINK IT'S
S ON FOR
RUSSIA IVERY
ED WITCTBUT DEEP BIS THE EST HO
VICTORBECAUSS AT'S NAZ BUT  VERE
SOVIET PEOPLE WENT.AS VER
BU HIS HAS BECOME CORE
Y LOOKOLOGY, WHAT RUSSIA
THERE'S ONE GROU OF E
FOR YOUNPELEG
ARMY, YOUTH OR ARMY.
M TT INOF THEIR
RELY PRECISELY, WILL HE PUTILL
SAY MISSIOME
HED I THINLE TO SAY THATALH THE
STATE TV SAD
OF THIS T WORTHAOMISSO T H THAT.
T  AO BROADEN IT,  T AGN
QURSE, BUT TIG
AGAINST WH HE PERCAS O-NAZIR.
IMPORTANT PART.
PEOPLE OF RUSSIA WILL
WATCHING AND LISTENING
CAREFUY,O RLEADER, JILL, WHETHED
L HAVE OBVIOUSLY CE
JUST ABOUTDING REPETITION OF HO
APS TO BE RPRETED AS A WARNING F
FORCE.
>> YES
KNOW, IN THI OAY, BECAUSE YO
THERE WILL BE, MAY
WILL B
THWIA PARADE.
IT A REAEE OF TH
NS, YO G
INNDT1945.
GRANDPEND BACK
IN5 T E,G PEOPLEMPLISHING FOR IA
RD AREN E POLITISPECTRUMWHAT HA
SIDE. EVERYBODY HAS AATIVE.
SOSAG THOS
DOIOW.
>> O,
MORNING.AWSSEARSALMOSCOW FAYthG
WHATO INL
UKRAINE E WE HAVURSE,  D E REPU
EXPECTING TO SEE HERE?N THE ISS
IN THE HDSE STATUE.
E SOVIET GIIN
'S TENDENCY ME
, I THINK E GOINGE THAT.IT MIGH
LILE
WHESE
CIRCUMSTANAI THE OT
.
HAS BEENAYING, AND WE
FT
RU INO
N UKRAINE.SO, ER
PUTIN
ITI IN HY HERE BSEE ENY IS KR O
IT BE, BUT IBRHAT IDEA TPERSON H
QUOTESS PUTIN ISTO